Giyu from Demon Slayer is an insanely powerful
swordsman who HATES demons.
But what if somehow he was suddenly turned
into a demon himself.
How strong would he be?
And how would his transformation COMPLETELY
change the story?
And we have to begin all the way back in episode
one where Giyu ABSOLUTELY MUST still be a
human.
Because honestly if Giyu isn’t here to save
Tanjiro from his demon sister, then the main
character would probably have died right here
and the story would be over.
So let’s assume that this all stays the
same and Giyu sends Tanjiro to meet with this
former Water Hashira to begin his training.
Now you may not remember, but Tanjiro spent
about TWO WHOLE YEARS training here, so this
is THE PERFECT time period for Giyu’s unfortunate
transformation., and is going to perfectly
set up the HEART-BREAKING final battle involving
Demon Giyu, Tanjiro, and two other Hashira.
So let’s imagine that Giyu somehow runs
into the Demon King Muzan and he would of
course get CRUSHED if he even decided to fight
at all.
But let’s assume Muzan doesn’t want to
waste such a powerful fighter so he offers
to change Giyu into a demon.
Now I have to say that there is ABSOLUTELY
NO CHANCE that Giyu would choose to become.
I mean he would literally kill his friends
if they were to become demons, but for the
sake of this scenario let’s say that Muzan
forces him to transform.
Which would be COMPLETE TORTURE for Giyu,
but he would definitely survive and likely
try to hold onto his memory of Tanjiro and
Nezuko.
That’s because he might think that if Nezuko
can survive without eating humans then he
should be able to as well.
Right?
But Muzan would probably anticipate this,
so during the roughly two to three days this
transformation is happening the demon king
is going to do two things, one of which is
completely messed up.
First he takes Giyu to some place where he
cannot kill himself by going out into the
sun.
Say somewhere like the infinity castle where
he is completely under Muzan’s control.
And second Muzan sends one of the higher ranking
Upper Moon demons to kidnap Giyu’s former
mentor, Urokodaki, to take him hostage.
Now you might be thinking “well wait, wasn’t
Tanjiro still training?”
but let’s say this happens while Tanjiro
is away taking his Final Selection test.
And while Urokodaki is strong and he would
probably kill himself before being taken captive,
let’s assume that he is knocked unconscious
and then taken back to Muzan.
Now this means that on top of being WILDLY
HUNGRY after his demon transformation, Giyu
now has his mentor to worry about too.
And I think all of this pressure will eventually
lead him to break down, forget his desire
to remain a good demon like Nezuko, and finally
eat a human to stay alive.
Which is going to alter his normally bland
personality somewhat PLUS now that he’s
a demon we have to ask the MOST IMPORTANT
question.
How powerful is Demon Giyu?
Well of course he will have the ridiculous
strength, endurance, and healing that all
powerful demons possess.
But how about his blood demon art?
And his new demonic appearance?
Well, keep watching to see his INSANE design
and new powers, but we first must discuss
how his transformation is going to change
the story.
Because remember that this is all happening
while Tanjiro is taking his final selection
exam.
So when he is ready to fully join the demon
slayers he is going to have a MASSIVE SHOCK
when he learns the HORRIBLE FATE of the only
two demon slayers he really knows.
Talk about a rough start to a new job.
Now there are a few things that could happen
next.
Tanjiro might be desperate to try and save
them, but honestly he is nowhere near strong
enough to attempt any sort of rescue, so for
now the story will progress as normal.
That means Tanjiro will still go to Mount
Natagumo to fight the spider demon family,
but instead of Giyu showing up to rescue it
will probably be someone else like the Flame
Hashira Rengoku, who should be strong enough
to easily take out the Lower Rank Five Demon.
And while we’re talking about the Hashira,
I think it is fair to assume that the other
Hashira will NOT take the news about Giyu’s
transformation well AT ALL.
Some of them like the Wind Hashira Sanemi
and the Serpent Hashira Obanai will probably
even want to go hunt him down IMMEDIATELY.
And speaking of Demon Giyu, I already mentioned
that eating humans for the first time would
probably change his personality, so at this
point he would probably be losing his grip
on his humanity and be out hunting down humans
and eating them to grow stronger.
So there is a decent chance that the Hashira
could find Giyu somewhere, but for now let’s
assume that he avoids fighting against any
of the strongest demon slayers.
Which defintely won’t last forever, as we’ll
see in just a few moments.
Now there’s one other disclaimer I have
to mention and that is because as a Hashira
Giyu would probably know a TON of super secret
information that Muzan would love to get his
hands on.
For example, the location of the Demon Slayer
Corps Headquarters or the swordsmith village,
but for this scenario let’s assume that
Demon Giyu has lost some of his memories because
it would basically be the end of the demon
slayers if Muzan had that information at this
time.
While months pass and Demon Giyu grows stronger,
Tanjiro goes on his missions, nearly dies
multiple times, and spends a ton of time recovering.
At the end of all this, Giyu would probably
have already climbed the ranks of the Lower
Moon Demons and be ready to challenge for
the top six spots.
That’s because even though he has only had
a few months to master his new body and skills,
we know that insanely strong humans usually
turn into insanely strong demons with more
of Muzan’s blood, so now Demon Giyu is ready
to make a push to become an Upper Moon ranked
demon.
Now in case you don’t know, there isn’t
some special tournament or something that
the demons use to rank themselves.
Instead, a demon can only become ranked by
earning Muzan’s favor.
And the best way to do that is to do something
extraordinary or to just be super powerful.
So to do this let’s say that instead of
just killing hundreds of people Giyu tricks
someone like the Upper Moon 5 demon Gyokko
into a fight.
Now we know that demons can’t usually kill
each other and they don’t often fight, but
it does happen from time to time because we
were told in a fan book that the Upper Moon
Three has challenged the Upper Moon One multiple
times.
So let’s just imagine that Giyu insults
Gyokko’s creepy artwork or something and
they square off to fight.
Which means it is FINALLY TIME to see what
he looks like AND his new powers in action.
This is his new demon form which is mostly
his same human form with a few incredible
changes.
First he has these icy-blue lines that cover
parts of his body like cracked ice.
He still uses a sword, but we’ll see what
kind of new blade he has in just a moment.
Then to cap it all off he has this long, dragon-like
tail.
And we’re going to see his new powers in
action right away because when Gyokko unleashes
thousands of demon fish at Giyu, the Hashira
Demon pulls out his sword and the entire group
of fish instantly freezes.
And I mean they literally freeze because Giyu’s
blade is actually an ice-sword made from his
blood demon art.
That’s because I combined his normally chilly
personality with his Water Breathing form
to create an ice-blood demon art which allows
him to freeze things.
Which is going to be super effective against
Gyokko because Giyu can even make it so cold
that it can somewhat freeze the blood in the
Upper Moon Five’s body.
So with this the former Hashira slices through
Gyokko’s body and easily puts an end to
the duel.
Which certainly will be enough to earn Muzan’s
favor and promote Giyu into Gyokko’s spot
as the Upper Moon five.
But before Giyu leaves, he makes Gyokko reveal
the location of the Swordsmith Village.
Now, if you are caught up with the anime then
you might be able to predict where this is
going next.
Because while Tanjiro has been off fighting
on the Mugen train and in the Entertainment
District, he has broken his sword which means
he is off to the Swordsmith Village for a
new one.
And all is going well at first, but after
a few nights here things start to get chilly.
Because in the original story, the Upper Moon
Four Demon and Gyokko attacked the village
with the help of all these creepy fish demons.
But in this version, Gyokko is replaced by
Demon Giyu, so instead of the creepy fish,
we just have a bunch of random weaker demons
instead.
But this invasion sends the demon slayers
into battle including Tanjiro, Genya, the
Mist Hashira Muichiro, and eventually the
Love Hashira Mitsuri.
And hold onto your seats because in this battle
we are going to see ONE FINAL BETRAYAL that
will absolutely crush your heart.
And if you want more Demon Slayer Content
just like this, make sure to subscribe to
the channel.
Let’s kick it off with the first major change
to this arc.
Since there is no Gyokko in this battle, when
Muichio sprints back to the village after
being blasted away, he isn’t going to be
stopped by the former Upper Moon Five.
That means he can basically head straight
back to help Genya and Tanjiro face off against
the Upper Moon 4 Hantengu and his split personalities.
Which means that when Mitsuri finally arrives
back in the village, she’ll still be able
to slice through the weaker demons until she
reaches the village chief.
But this time instead of being crushed by
a giant fish, the village chief is already
dead…
And as she sees this Mitsuri’s skin starts
to shiver.
That’s because standing over the village
chief’s body is Demon Giyu with his icy
sword covered in blood.
And this is going to send Mitsuri ABSOLUTELY
FURIOUS.
Because while I don’t think she would have
been one of the Hashira who originally wanted
to hunt Giyu down, at this point there is
no turning back for the former demon.
Which is truly heart-breaking because Mitsuri
used to think Giyu was pretty timid and adorable,
but now she is determined to cut him down.
But first, Giyu’s dragon-like tail shoots
out and smacks Mitsuri.
Then the furious Hashira rushes Giyu with
her whip-like swords flashing in a million
different directions.
But before we see EPIC end of this fight,
first we have to say that on the other side
of the village, the fight against the Upper
Moon Four is going WAY SMOOTHER than in the
original story.
That’s because if we’re being honest,
Muichiro is one of THE STRONGEST Hashira.
So with him around Hantengu might not even
have time for his personalities to combine
into their ultimate form before Muichiro or
Tanjiro cut the head off of his actual body.
So with one Upper Moon Demon down, they head
back into the village to find it COMPLETELY
COVERED IN ICE.
Uh-oh.
Unfortunately, they find random demons still
attacking the village AND WORST OF ALL, Demon
Giyu is standing over the dead body of Mitsuri
with his demonic tail covering her body.
Whew…
Okay.
No more sympathy for Giyu.
He needs to DIE.
NOW!
Because while you might say he was forced
to become a demon and then blackmailed into
eating humans, at this point I think he has
completely lost his humanity.
Which is tragic because even though I think
Tanjiro would still try to turn Giyu into
a good demon, there is no chance of it working
now.
Which means that OF COURSE they will have
to fight, and honestly there are many ways
that this battle could go.
Giyu’s Blood Demon art is BROKEN with his
icy blade and his ability to even freeze people’s
blood somewhat, but I think Tanjiro and especially
Muichiro at this point would be strong enough
to resist that.
Although it is honestly hard to say if they
would win or not.
I mean like I said Muichiro is EXTREMELY STRONG
with some of the best feats in the original
story.
I would definitely put him above human Giyu,
but as a demon it is harder to say.
Nonetheless though, it is nearly impossible
to say who would actually win this fight,
but without a doubt it would be a DEVASTATING
BATTLE both physically and EMOTIONALLY for
Tanjiro.
However, one thing that would make the fight
WAY EASIER for the heroes is if they actually
had another strong demon to fight on their
side.
Who am I talking about?
Well, in this altered timeline it is also
possible that Rengoku ACTUALLY AGREED to become
a demon during the Mugen Train Arc, and if
you want to see Demon Rengoku’s UNBELIEVABLE
POWERS and his heartbreaking sacrifice in
that version of the story, you can watch this
video right here.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.